[Music]
so shiny for python if you're not
already familiar with shiny
shiny is a framework for
building interactive web applications
so it's been
almost 10 years to the date that we've
had shiny in r
but over the past year or so we've been
working on
essentially porting that foundation over
to python
so that you know python users can have a
similar very approachable
framework for building interactive web
applications without
needing to already know html css and
javascript so even though we try to make
this approachable we still sort of build
this on a foundation that's very
flexible and scalable
so
these are kind of built on
foundations that allow you to you know
build out your own custom components
sort of extend some of the reactivity
concepts to you know implement your own
sort of
modular you know functionalities
and
also
you know
the sort of reactive framework that
powers all of this the one of the
reasons why it's so nice is it kind of
allows you to click to declare you know
what should happen and then shiny
handles the details of you know what
actual computations to execute when they
need to be executed
so it kind of
allows you to write this expressive
reactive code without needing to handle
like every specific case of when this
changes then also update this other
thing so for a very sort of hello world
example you can see it here running in
the browser
and this is how
you would start programming a very basic
shiny application
so you can see i'm importing from shiny
there's a ui package inside of shiny so
this is how you'll actually
create or define
where things should go in the actual
user interface of the shiny application
there's also a rendering package and
this is
sort of utilities for
rendering things like matplotlib plots
or
various different types of python output
into actual stuff that can go into a
user interface
and then every shiny application is
going to want this capital a app
to actually
bring the two main pieces of the shiny
app together
that being the user interface here from
lines three to six this is the
definition of what you see on the right
here
as well as the server logic which kind
of takes
python objects and renders them into
things that can go into the user user
interface
so in this particular
basic example i have created this user
interface by
first creating a sort of like a page
container so we have several different
variants on
different types of pages that you can
create page fluid in a lot of cases is
you know it's it's pretty basic but
covers
most use cases for just starting a new
user interface
and then inside of there i will put a
slider component
and
give this an id of lowercase n
and then this is a label that should
appear just above the slider so i'm
going to put a capital n
for label
define the minimum and the maximum for
the slider and then a starting value for
that slider and the way that shiny works
is um
you know you basically in this user
interface you give every kind of user
interface component an id
and then you can reference
um whatever the current value of that
input is on the server by saying input
dot n and then you kind of
read that value by calling it like a
function
so if i had several different
input components with different ids
i would you know of course change the
name here after the dot and then call it
like a function to basically read
whatever the current value is and you
might have noticed in this server
definition
when you define this server function
uh it takes three arguments the input
values that are coming in from this user
interface
uh the
um
an output argument and we're going to
use this
output
object to basically
hook up
values that we create on the server up
with the user interface
and then also a session which we're not
going to get into here but this can um
allow you to do things specific to a
specific user's session experience all
right so with the server definition
i'm going to create an output
that's going to be connected to this
output text verbatim with an id of text
and with every output
when you first create it you're going to
want to then um
provide a rendering
decorator
so here that
at render.txt
basically means i want to define a
function that's going to return a string
that i can just put verbatim into this
this
whatever ui component i'm hooking up
this return value to
and this part right here the actual name
of this function that i'm providing to
the render text and the output decorator
is going to define
the output id essentially that will that
should match this
you know sort of ui container that i
want to hook up this this value to now
that i've kind of declared that there's
an output that i want to render as text
with an id of text or txt and provide it
inside of
provide this sort of function expression
that
reads
a reactive value this input dot n
by declaring it this way then shiny
knows basically whenever this input
n changes i will re-execute this
function
and basically you know create a new
return value for this text verbatim
here
so that's a long way of saying like
whenever i change this slider value here
this gray text box below is going to
update to be two times whatever the
value this slider is a neat thing about
this that i don't really want to
steal my colleague winston's thunder too
much on
is the fact that this is all running in
the browser
so
we've kind of built this foundation for
allowing you to take you know simple
shiny applications and run them purely
in the browser without a python process
running in the background
so this is actually statically hosted on
netlify through github pages
and i have a running shiny application
here that i can actually
modify the source code of this shiny
application and say i want maybe five
times the current value of this slider
restart it's going to start with an
initial value of 40
here and now i've got 5 times 40
in the output so that's just kind of a
neat side note that you'll notice as i'm
kind of going through more examples some
of these will just run purely in the
browser um but you could learn more
about that in another video currently i
don't i don't know if this link will
change at any point i would imagine that
it will eventually
have
the company's branding and everything in
the link name
but for now yes pyshiny.netify.app
is the best place to go to and then
there's kind of some get getting started
stuff
some information on how to install
information about how to deploy to our
different like professional products
going into some concepts in depth
and then there's a link here to examples
that
is kind of a different site with all
sorts of different examples that are
running in the browser
[Music]